Welcome back.
I'm now going to use definite
integrals to figure out the
areas under a bunch of curves
and, if we have time, maybe
even between some curves.
So let me right down the
fundamental theorem
of calculus.
I know I covered it really fast
in the last presentation.
Just to make sure you
understand this formula.
The last couple presentations
were really to give you an
intuition for this
exact formula.
Let's say that big f prime of
x is equal to f of x, right?
That's also like saying that
the -- that's equivalent to
saying that f of x -- big f
of x -- is equal to the
antiderivative of
f of x, right?
Well, let's just that it's one
of the possible antiderivatives
of f of x, right?
Because there's always a
constant term here and you're
not sure whether it is.
And this is why people tend to
use this standard because we
know that f of x is the
derivative of big f prime of x.
Big f of x is just one of the
antiderivatives of f of x.
So this is a little bit
not true, but I think
you get the idea.
But the fundamental theorem of
calculus tells us if this top
line is true, then the definite
integral from a to b of f of x
d x is equal to its
antiderivative evaluated at b
minus its antiderivative
evaluated at a.
And I know I said here that
big f isn't the only
antiderivative, right?
Because you could at any
constant to this and that would
also be the antiderivative.
But when you subtract here, the
constants will cancel out.
So it really doesn't
matter which of the
constants you pick.
The constant actually
doesn't matter.
So that's why I actually
said the antiderivative.
But let's apply this.
You might be
confused right now.
So let me draw a graph.
There you go.
Look how straight that is.
Draw the x-axis.
Not perfect but it'll do.
Let's say that my f of x is
equal to x squared plus 1.
So f of x looks like this.
This is 1.
So it'll start at 1.
It'll just be a parabola.
Let me see how good
I can draw this.
I've done worse.
OK.
So that's f of x.
It's a parabola.
y-intercept at 1.
And let's say I want to figure
out the area under the curve --
between the curve and,
really, the x-axis.
Let's say I want to figure out
the area between the curve and
the x-axis from x equals
negative 1 to, I don't
know, x equals 3.
So this is the area I
want to figure out.
I'm going to shade it in.
So this is the area.
All of this stuff.
I want to figure out this area.
And you could imagine, before
you knew calculus, figuring out
an area of something with a
curve -- it's kind
of top boundary.
It would have been
very difficult.
But we will now use the
fundamental theorem of calculus
and hopefully you have an
intuition of why this works and
how the integral is really just
a sum of a bunch of little,
little, small squares with
infinitely small bases.
But if you watched the last
videos, hopefully that
hit the point home.
But now we'll just mechanically
compute because, actually,
understanding it is a bit
harder than just doing it.
But let's just
mechanically compute it.
So we are essentially just
going to figure out the
integral from minus 1 to 3
of f of x, which is x
squared plus 1 d x.
What's the antiderivative
of x squared plus 1?
This just equals the
antiderivative.
So it's just x to the third --
we could say 1/3 x to the third
or x to the third over
3 -- plus x, right?
The derivative of x is 1.
And then we don't have to worry
about plus c because we're
going to subtract out the c's.
You'll see.
I think you'll get the point.
It doesn't matter.
You could pick an arbitrary
c right here and it'll
just cancel out.
And we're going to evaluate
that at 3 and negative 1 and
we're going to subtract
out big f of negative
1 from big f of 3.
This is just the
notation they use.
You figure out the
antiderivative and
you say where you're
going to evaluate it.
And then this is equal to
-- So if I evaluate 3.
3 to the third power is what?
That's 27.
27 divided by 3 is 9.
And then 9 plus 3 is 12.
Right?
This is just big f of 3, right?
Because I figured out the
end -- This is big f of x.
You can kind of view
this as big f of x.
But not to be confused with
small, cursive f of x.
This is big f of x.
So this big f of 3.
And then, from that
we'll subtract big f
of negative 1, right?
Minus big f of negative 1.
And if we put minus 1 here.
Let's see, minus 1 to the
third power is minus 1.
So it's minus 1/3 and then
plus minus 1, right?
So minus 1/3 plus minus 1.
I think that equals
minus 4/3, correct?
I think so.
Maybe I'm making a mistake
with negative signs.
Minus 1/3 minus 4/3.
And I'm going to
subtract that, right?
So if I'm subtracting minus
4/3, it's the same thing
as adding minus 4/3.
And then we have our answer.
Actually, it's 12 and 4/3
-- whatever -- units.
Squared units.
12 and 4/3 squared units.
We could write this as a
mixed number as well.
Let's do another one.
I'll do a slight variation.
OK.
Let me draw again.
Some coordinates.
I don't know if I'm going
to have time to do it in
this video but I'll try.
I always try.
Let's say I have f of x is
equal to the square root of x.
So it looks something
like this.
That's actually a pretty nice
looking, kind of sideways
parabola, I think.
This is f of x.
And let's say I have
another function.
g of x which equals x squared.
So g of x is actually going
to look something like this.
Whoops!
I was doing well and then
something happened.
And, of course, it'll continue
on this side as well.
Because it is defined
for negative numbers.
But anyway, my question to you,
or my question to myself,
really, is what is the
area between the curves
where they intersect?
What is this?
What is this area?
Well, the first thing you have
to figure out is just what
are the boundary points?
What is this point?
And what is this point?
Well this point, I
think, is pretty clear.
It's 0, 0, right?
They both intersect at 0, 0.
And even this point, you could
probably do it from intuition.
But if you don't, I guess, want
to do it through intuition, you
could just set these 2
equations equal to
each other, right?
You could say x squared
is equal to the square
root of x, right?
And then you could do
a bunch of things.
You could square both sides or
-- well, actually, this is the
same thing as doing
it by intuition.
But I think it's pretty obvious
that the only places where x
squared is equal to the square
root of x are the points x
equals 0, which you already
know, and x equals 1.
So this is the point 1, 1.
Which is true for both of them.
And this is more algebra,
so I won't go into that
in too much detail.
I'm kind of running
out of time.
So we want to figure out the
area between these 2 curves.
So what we can do is -- maybe
you want to pause it and think
about it yourself -- we
can figure out the area
under the grey curve.
We could figure out this area.
So we want to figure out --
this is a boundary, right?
Between 0 and 1.
We could figure out this area
and then we could figure out
the entire area under the green
curve separately and then we
could subtract the difference.
Which is exactly how we're
going to do it in the next
video because I have
run out of time.